BRIAN: YOU ARE LOOKING LIVE AT
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY AS BORDER
PATROLS ARE ROUNDING UP A GROUP
OF MIGRANTS.
WE HAVE A DRONE SHOT.
WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT THIS
IS ONCE UPON A TIME THE MIGRANTS
WOULD REACH ACROSS THE BORDER
AND SCATTER BUT NOW THEY ARE
WAITING IN PLACE FOR BORDER
PATROL TO TURN THEMSELVES IN
BECAUSE IF YOU ARE AN
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR CHILD OR A
FAMILY FOR THE MOST PART IT IS
AN EASY PATH TO GET INTO THE
UNITED STATES, TO TURN YOURSELF
IN AND PROCESS YOU AT ONE OF
THOSE JAIL LIKE FACILITIES, THE
NEXT STOP IS SOMEPLACE IN
AMERICA.
AINSLEY: SOME SINGLE
INDIVIDUALS, UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN, MOST OF THE FAMILIES
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS FROM
THIS PAST FEBRUARY COMPARED TO
LAST FEBRUARY IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY.
TUCKER CARLSON HIS HOST OF
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT.
LET’S MISS YOU ON THE MORNING
SHOW.
IS THAT THE BIGGEST ISSUE RIGHT
NOW?
>> Reporter: UNLIKE SO MANY
ISSUES WE FACE, THIS ONE WILL
CHANGE THE COUNTRY FOREVER.
THE STAKES COULDN’T BE HIGHER,
THE QUESTION OF WHO LIVES HERE
IS THE CENTRAL QUESTION FOR
DEMOCRACY.
WHEN YOU CHANGE THE POPULATION
YOU CHANGE THE OUTCOME OF THE
VOTE.
YOU CHANGE THE WAY THE COUNTRY
IS RUN AND THAT IS THE POINT OF
THIS.
THIS COUNTRY HAS GAINED 100
MILLION PEOPLE, MOST AMERICANS
ARE NOT EVEN AWARE OF THAT.
MASSIVE DEMOCRATIC CHANGES NOT
ENOUGH FOR THE CHANGES.
THIS IS AN EFFORT BASICALLY, IF
YOU OPENED THE BORDERS AND
SPONSOR LEGISLATION GIVING
CITIZENSHIP AND VOTING RIGHTS,
YOU ARE TRYING TO CHANGE
ELECTION OUTCOMES.
BRIAN: THOSE WHO THINK THE
HISPANIC THE GHOST OF DEMOCRATS
DIDN’T PAY ATTENTION TO THE LAST
ELECTION, A LOT OF PRECINCT IN
TEXAS IN PARTICULAR, EIGHT IN
ALL MOSTLY HISPANIC, THEY ARE
GETTING 9000 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
DAILY.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE 11,000
CHILDREN, MORE LIKE 12 IN HHS,
5067 CVP.
I DON’T UNDERSTAND, YOU CAN SEE
THE BIGGER PICTURE BETTER THAN I
CAN.
HOW DOES THIS HELP PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S ADMINISTRATION, A 70%
APPROVAL RATING, $1.9 TRILLION
HE JUST GOT, HE WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT ALL THESE PROGRAMS THAT
ALL ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT EVEN DEMOCRAT IN OTHER
NETWORKS IS THIS.
HOW DOES THIS HELP JOE BIDEN.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
EXTREMELY FRUSTRATED BY THE IDEA
THERE ARE AMERICANS WHO DON’T
VOTE FOR THEM.
IF YOU CHANGE THE NATURE OF
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE, PEOPLE
THINKING LONGER TERMS, ONLY 2
AND A HALF MONTHS INTO THE
ADMINISTRATION, 10 YEARS AHEAD,
WHICH IS THE WAY THEY THINK IN A
MUCH BROADER WAY, THE QUESTION
IS WHAT IS HAPPENING?
A LOT OF THEM ARE BEING FLOWN
INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE
COUNTRY.
WE WILL HAVE THE STORY TONIGHT
AT 8:00, THEY ARE PLACED IN
FOSTER FAMILIES IN STATES VERY
FAR FROM THE US BORDER.
IF THAT IS TRUE IT IS AN AMAZING
STORY, THEY GOT BIDEN ELECTED,
THERE HAS BEEN A NEWS BLACKOUT
ON WHAT IS HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER, HUGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE,
WHERE ARE THEY EXACTLY?
NOT ALL IN TEXAS, ARIZONA, NEW
MEXICO AND CALIFORNIA.
BRIAN: DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ONE IMAGE OF KIDS
IN THAT ROOM THAT HAD THE
CHAIN-LINK FENCING CLOSURE THE
MEDIA MELTED DOWN AND SAID KIDS
IN CAGES.
THEY ARE IN THE SAME CAGES, IT
IS NOT THE OUTCOME WE SAW AND
WHAT IS DIFFERENT ABOUT NOW,
THERE’S A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
OUT OF THE WHITE HOUSE
APPARENTLY THE PRESIDENT OF
GUATEMALA, THE FAMILY COMING
INTO GUATEMALA MIGHT HAVE COVID
WHICH IS IRONIC BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION RELEASED
UNTOLD REGIONS OF MIGRANTS IN
THE UNITED STATES WITHOUT EVER
TESTING FOR COVID.
WE GOT TO BRING THE END TO COVID
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THE
LOOPHOLE, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
WORRY ABOUT COVID EXCEPT THOSE
COMING INTO THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> TO HOLD A JOB, AFTER THEY
HAVE A VACCINE AND REMAIN IN
TERROR OF THE VIRUS AFTER YOU
GET THE VACCINE.
AND ANOTHER EXAMPLE, TO THE
INTEREST OF AMERICAN CITIZENS,
THEY ARE HOMELESS, NO ONE SEEMS
TO NOTICE THEY ARE THERE UNLESS
YOU LIVE IN A BIG CITY.
YOU ARE PAYING FOR HOTEL ROOMS,
FOREIGN NATIONALS WHO BROKE OUR
LAWS TO GET HERE, YOU ARE
RUNNING THE US GOVERNMENT YOU’VE
GOT TO CARE ABOUT US CITIZENS
FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT IS YOUR
JOB.
AINSLEY: IN CALIFORNIA AND SAN
DIEGO, THE CONVENTION CENTER,
ASKING TAXPAYERS TO -- WHO
HAVEN’T BEEN IN SCHOOL MORE THAN
A YEAR, YOU NEED TO KEEP ZOOMING
OR VIRTUAL LEARNING BUT YOUR TAX
DOLLARS NEED TO GO TOWARD
MIGRANT CHILDREN WHO ARE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
WE WILL PAY FOR THEM TO GET AN
EDUCATION, ASKING TEACHERS TO
COME TO THE CONVENTION CENTER
AND VOLUNTEER IN PERSON ON
SPRING BREAK RIGHT NOW TO COME
IN AND TEACH MIGRANT CHILDREN,
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT BE
CHANGE KEEPING AMERICAN CHILDREN
OUT OF SCHOOL FOR A YEAR IS ONE
OF THE COOLEST THINGS THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER DONE AND IT
TELLS YOU THE POWER OF THE
TEACHERS UNIONS.
THERE IS NO SCIENTIFIC BASIS FOR
THE POLICY.
IT HAS KILLED A LOT OF PEOPLE,
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AMONG
CHILDREN SKYROCKETED, WE
INTERVIEWED PARENTS OF KIDS WHO
KILLED THEMSELVES BECAUSE THE
ISOLATION OF THE LOCKDOWNS AND
YET THEY ARE PUTTING ONCE AGAIN
THE PRIORITY ON FOREIGN
NATIONALS.
IT IS NOT AGAINST MIGRANTS KIDS
BUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEY
IGNORE AMERICAN KIDS IS SHOCKING
AND BY THE WAY CALIFORNIA HAS
CANES 10 MILLION PEOPLE NET
SINCE 1990, 10 MILLION.
IT HAS GOTTEN MUCH WORSE.
IMMIGRATION IS THE MAIN DRIVER
OF POPULATION GROWTH, PEOPLE ARE
LEAVING, THE STATE EVERY YEAR
GETS WORSE FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS.
PEOPLE ARE NOT ASKING HOW IS
THIS GOING TO PROVE OUR COUNTRY,
IT IS NOT.
NO ONE IS ARGUING THAT IT IS.
I THINK REPUBLICANS NEED TO WAKE
UP AND SEE THE BIG PICTURE WHICH
IS THE COUNTRY WILL BE CHANGED
FOREVER AND NO ONE IS MAKING THE
CASE THAT WILL IMPROVE.
BRIAN: I GAVE YOU TIME TO RUN
YOUR STATING CALIFORNIA, WHAT
YOU GAVE US BACK WAS
HOMELESSNESS AND KIDS WHO DON’T
GO TO SCHOOL.
A LOCKDOWN STAY WITH NUMBERS
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN NEW YORK
AND HIGHER THAN TEXAS AND NEW
YORK AND TEXAS AND FLORIDA,
LET’S TALK ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE
THAT IS GETTING A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY AND THAT IS WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU GET VACCINATED.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT A VACCINE
PASSPORT, THEN YOU CAN GO TO
THAT GAME OR GO TO THAT PLANE
AND IF NOT MAYBE YOU DON’T.
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS IN A STATE
YOUR FAMILY WITH, FLORIDA, SAYS
THIS ABOUT THE CONCEPT OF
VACCINE PASSPORTS.
>> IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE
FOR THE GOVERNMENT OR THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO IMPOSE UPON
YOU THE REQUIREMENT THAT YOU
SHOW PROOF OF VACCINE TO
PARTICIPATE IN NORMAL SOCIETY.
YOU WANT THE FOX TO GUARD THE
HEN HOUSE?
GIVE ME A BREAK, THIS HAS HUGE
PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS.
IT IS NOT NECESSARY TO DO.
BRIAN: WHERE DO YOU STAND?
>> WISER LEFT TO THE GOVERNOR OF
FLORIDA TO SAY THAT?
50 REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE,
WHITE THEY AREN’T STAYING WE ARE
NOT DOING THIS, YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO KNOW IF
YOUR KID HAS A SEX CHANGE AND
NOW YOUR PRIVATE, WHETHER YOU
ARE VACCINATED OR NOT, THAT
INFORMATION IN THE HANDS OF THE
TECH COMPANIES AND THAT WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER YOU
PARTICIPATE IN AMERICAN LIFE?
IF YOU’RE TRYING TO CALM PEOPLE
DOWN ABOUT THE IDEA OF VACCINES
AND MAKE THEM LESS VACCINE
HESITANT AND CONVINCE THEM IT IS
NOT A CONSPIRACY RUN BY BILL
GATES THEN YOU WON’T CONSIDER
DOING SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THE AMOUNT OF PARANOIA, FEAR AND
DISTRUST AND SOCIAL DIVISION
THIS POLICY WILL ENGENDER IS
IMPOSSIBLE TO CALCULATE.
IF YOU WANT TO DIVIDE AMERICAN
SOCIETY FOR THE YOU WOULD GO
AHEAD AND DO SOMETHING ORWELLIAN
LIKE THIS.
THEY DON’T CARE BUT WHERE ARE
THE DEFENDERS OF, I DON’T KNOW,
THE AMERICAN WAY?
THEY SHOULD BE OUTRAGED BY THIS.
PETE: SOMETHING WE WILL HEAR A
LOT MORE OF.
IF YOU MOVE YOUR HAND A LITTLE
BIT WE COULD SEE THE LINE THAT
SAYS TUCKER CARLSON TODAY, RIGHT
THERE.
AINSLEY: TUCKER CHANGED HIS
NAME.
PETE: WE LOVE THE NEW SET.
YOU’VE GOT SOME WOOD PANELING,
THIS IS THE OFFICIAL HOME OF
TUCKER CARLSON TODAY.
>> I LIKE WOOD.
WOOD WAS ALIVE.
THE GREATEST BUILDING MATERIAL
THERE IS.
I LIKE BEING SURROUNDED BY IT.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO DEEPER AND
LONGER WITH INTERESTING PEOPLE.
I TALK LESS, THEY TALK MORE.
EVERYONE LEARNS A LOT, FUTURE
INTERESTING, THESE INTERVIEWS
CAN GO ON FOR QUITE SOME TIME
AND IF YOU LIKE LONGFORM AND I
THINK THERE’S A PLACE FOR IT IT
IS GREAT.
IT IS NOT DIFFICULT TO GET BUT
IF YOU GO TO FOXNATION.COM WHICH
I DID SATURDAY I WAS EXPECTING
--
BRIAN: FIRST TIME YOU’VE GONE ON
FOX NATION?
AINSLEY: WHEN YOU GET YOUR SHOW
-- TO SIGN UP.
>> I WORK HERE SO I HAVE FREE
ACCESS.
I WILL DO IT AND IT IS NOT HARD.
I CAN BARELY OPERATE MY IPAD.
BRIAN: YOU AND HIM HAVE QUALITY
TIME.
>> IN AN UGLY DIRECTION.
TO POLITICIZE ART, ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE MEANINGFUL IN
OUR LIVES, TICK-TOCK, SPLINTER
THE CYCLE OF POLITICS.
BRIAN: IS THAT YOUR FIRST
EPISODE?
WE SPLIT IT UP INTO A COUPLE
HOURS.
BY THE END OF THAT INTERVIEW I
WAS SO RELIEVED AND REASSURED.
HE HAS THIS OVERVIEW ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT THAT CHANGED MY VIEW.
>> DO YOU WANT TO FILL IN ON
"FOX AND FRIENDS" AT ALL LIKE
YOU USED TO?
>> THAT IS THE TOUGHEST, I HOPE
YOUR AUDIENCE UNDERSTANDS HOW
HARD IT IS TO WAKE UP 3 IN THE
MORNING AND DO 3 HOURS.
I’M FILLED WITH AND RESPECT.
BRIAN: HE TURNED DOWN THE SHIFT
EVERY DAY.
TUCKER CARLSON TODAY IN THE NEW
RANCH HOUSE IS AVAILABLE ON FOX
NATION, MONDAYS, WEDNESDAYS AND
FRIDAYS.
GO TO FOXNATION.COM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GETTING